Trascrizione: Francesca Ramon
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Ho fatto il maestro per 40 anni,
e sono qua per dire una sola cosa,
a cui tengo veramente molto:
che i pensieri dei bambini,
delle bambine e dei bambini,
sono molto sottili.
Certe volte sono audaci,
arrivano a scavare profondamente;
certe volte hanno
delle intuizioni straordinarie.
Però, la stragrande maggioranza
di questi pensieri si perdono.
E si perdono perché è un pensiero
che non viene ascoltato.
E se non c'è qualcuno che lo raccoglie,
quel pensiero sparisce.
E siccome noi, da quello
che ho sentito stasera,
abbiamo bisogno di un sacco
di intelligenza, ma veramente tanta,
di creatività, di pensiero
per come salvare questo nostro pianeta.
Penso che è importantissimo dare dignità
a tutti i pensieri
delle bambine e dei bambini.
Non è facile, evidentemente:
anzi, non è facile per niente.
Però c'è una cosa a cui,
insomma, credo molto.
Per esempio, mettere al centro
della relazione educativa il dialogo.
Che vuol dire "dialogo"?
Vuol dire che qualsiasi cosa
noi guardiamo, su cui ragioniamo -
un testo, una poesia una pittura -
deve diventare uno spunto
perché ciascuno possa dire
tutto quello che pensa.
E questo è molto importante:
perché in genere, a scuola,
diciamo quello che pensiamo noi;
e speriamo che loro ripetano
quello che pensiamo noi.
Ma questa è una perdita enorme,
perché se guardiamo
questo quadro di Giotto -
nell'ultima mia classe
abbiamo cominciato con Giotto.
Nel senso che cominciamo
sempre con un artista,
nella nostra scuola di Giove,
e quell'anno lì
stavamo guardando il Giotto.
Se io guardo questo quadro
con venti bambini e bambini,
io ho 40 occhi che guardano quel quadro:
e 40 occhi vedono un sacco di cose
che io, adesso, non vedo.
Se parliamo di tutto quello
che vediamo di questo quadro,
io non solo scopro molte più cose
di quelle che avrei scoperto da solo:
ma scopro qualcosa di Emma,
di Nisrim, di Peter.
Perché quando uno rimbalza
con un oggetto culturale,
dice sempre qualcosa di sé.
Se noi raccontiamo,
leggiamo un pezzo di Omero -
la storia del Ciclope,
bellissima: Ulisse, ecc. -
se ciascuno dice qualcosa
di quello che pensa, di quell'episodio,
sta dicendo qualcosa di sé.
E questo è importantissimo,
perché io penso che la comunità -
si trasforma una classe in comunità
quando ci stupiamo uno dell'altro.
Quando non ci stupiamo più uno dell'altro,
è finita: anche in famiglia.
Cioè, se uno non si stupisce più
della persona con cui sta,
non va bene.
E questo, rispetto ai bambini,
è importantissimo.
Se per caso incontrate dei bambini,
o perché fate gli insegnanti,
o siete genitori,
o avete dei ragazzi per casa -
cosa che, diciamo,
capita a molti genitori -
provate dopo una settimana a dire:
"Cosa ho imparato da lui?"
Se non avete imparato niente, non va bene.
L'urgenza - com'era? -
l'urgenza ha tolto l'essenza,
le cose essenziali, le cose importanti.
Perché io credo
che ascoltarsi reciprocamente
è un grande allenamento;
e non è un allenamento
facile, assolutamente.
Però voglio farvi qualche esempio,
perché ho imparato un sacco,
dai ragazzini, veramente tantissimo.
Anzi, diciamo che le poche cose che so
le ho imparate con loro.
Questo quadro l'abbiamo osservato
in prima elementare:
anzi, abbiamo cominciato a scrivere
inventando delle storie
sui quadri di Giotto, del ciclo di Assisi:
meravigliosi.
Maya, in terza elementare,
di fronte alla domanda di Mario che -
vi ricordate, nel 2015
ci fu quel bambino in Iran
che fu trovato morto sulla spiaggia.
Una fotografia terribile che colpì molto
l'immaginario, diciamo, nostro.
E Mario disse: perché le persone emigrano?
La domanda era seria.
E dissi: per rispondere a questa domanda,
ci lavoreremo sopra.
Siamo stati tutto l'anno,
su questa domanda.
Tutto l'anno su questa domanda:
abbiamo fatto grafici, interviste,
abbiamo fatto il nord
e sud del Mediterraneo.
La ricchezza, che età hanno:
tantissime cose.
E ho lavorato per un anno,
su questa domanda,
perché sono domande generative.
Solo che Maya, un giorno -
siccome con questo quadro
ci avevamo giocato in classe,
e dalla prima l'avevamo lasciato lì -
Maya ha detto: "Ma maestro,
ma il Mar Mediterraneo
è la spaccatura di Giotto! "
Sapete perché?
Perché in questo quadro,
qui c'è un ricco e qui c'è un povero.
Ora, se in una città
tra il ricco e il povero
c'è questo abisso, c'è questa spaccatura,
da questa spaccatura escono
i demoni, la città infestata.
C'è pure Francesco,
che cerca di mettere pace.
Questo quadro dice, esattamente,
la situazione in cui siamo noi adesso:
è questa.
Solo che Maya ha avuto
l'intuizione di dire:
"Il Mar Mediterraneo
è quella spaccatura lì".
Cioè che se c'è troppa differenza,
tra il ricco e il povero,
sicuramente noi siamo in mezzo ai demoni.
E infatti ci siamo, non c'è dubbio.
Allora è questo, che mi interessa.
Cioè mi interessa pensare
che le bambine e i bambini,
se messi in una condizione di pensare
delle cose profonde, importanti,
se si ascoltano le loro domande -
perché loro di domande importanti
ne fanno, e tante -
noi possiamo scavare un po' di più
nella nostra umanità,
forse scoprire un po'
di cose importanti, no?
Perché una delle cose
più importanti in assoluto
credo che sia l'ascolto reciproco.
Imparare ad ascoltare qualcuno
che dice una cosa diversa dalla mia
è un grande allenamento,
un grande allenamento per nulla facile.
E se non lo fa la scuola, chi lo fa?
Io sono sempre convinto che la scuola
o è un po' meglio della società,
o è meglio che non ci sia.
Ed essere un po' meglio,
rispetto all'infanzia,
credo riguardi, esattamente,
questa possibilità di elaborare la parola.
I bambini vivono tantissime esperienze
per la prima volta:
fin da piccoli piccoli, quando si alzano,
quando cominciano a guardare in alto,
la prima volta che vedono la luna,
la prima volta che disegnano
e nel loro disegno appare una figura,
e loro si emozionano tantissimo.
Tutte queste prime volte -
Pasolini dice "l'autenticità
della prima volta".
C'è un pezzo che ha scritto,
quando faceva il maestro.
E tutte queste prime volte
sono pensiero, sono parola.
Ma questa parola l'ha aiutata a emergere.
Ed è su questo che io
mi scervello come fare,
perché se noi abbiamo
una quantità enorme di popolazione
che ha abbandonato l'idea
che la conoscenza
sia possibilità di stare meglio,
stare meglio con se stessi,
e anche con gli altri,
che la conoscenza,
e tutte queste belle cose
che abbiamo visto qui questa sera -
ma guardate che tantissimi
sono privati da questa idea;
non ci credono proprio, non lo sanno.
Allora, arricchire le parole
dell'esperienza della prima volta
è una cosa importantissima.
Vi racconto un'altra cosa, poi smetto.
Abbiamo lavorato sulla non violenza:
l'ultimo anno, io volevo
dedicare un po' di tempo
al tema della non violenza.
Abbiamo visto i film di Gandhi,
abbiamo letto molte cose di Gandhi
e abbiamo ragionato sulla violenza.
È uno scandalo, la non-violenza;
non è per niente naturale.
La nonviolenza è una cosa molto,
molto difficile da -
perché un bambino dice sì sì,
la non-violenza, certo:
però se uno mi dà un pugno?
Cioè, non è per niente naturale:
è una delle costruzioni -
anzi, credo sia la costruzione culturale
più alta che ci sia, la più difficile.
Lavoriamo sulla nonviolenza,
e a un certo punto mi viene in mente
di proporgli di leggere dei brani,
dei pezzi di Lisistrata.
Lisistrata, io, la amo tantissimo:
è una commedia di Aristofane
in cui questo ragazzo -
Aristofane era giovanissimo
quando ha scritto Lisistrata -
era arrabbiato, furioso
con chi faceva la guerra.
Abitava ad Atene,
la città più bella del mondo.
Amava il teatro, la città
in cui tutti vorrebbero -
New York, insomma,
il posto più bello del mondo.
Stava lì, e questi si mettono a fare
la guerra del Peloponneso per trent'anni,
gli rovinano la vita.
Per tutta la vita, Aristofane ha scritto
commedie contro la guerra.
L'unico suo obiettivo
era contro la guerra.
Lisistrata, voi lo sapete - è bellissima,
perché c'è questa idea geniale
che le donne smettono di fare sesso,
di fare l'amore con i loro uomini.
Finché non smettono
di fare la guerra, noi -
Immaginate i bambini
che si mettono, i maschi -
Ci siamo divertiti:
c'erano queste due fazioni sulla scena.
C'è un teatro.
I maschi, le femmine.
Quelle conquistano il tempio,
perché lì ci sono i soldi
per fare la guerra, ormai:
è abbastanza attuale come commedia.
A un certo punto un bambino,
mentre facevamo le prove,
diceva: "È successo davvero?"
Al ragazzo dico: no.
"Come non è successo?
Ma cos'è tutto questo sforzo
che stiamo facendo? "
"No, non è successo."
Io torno a casa sono dispiaciutissimo,
perché ci sono rimasti male,
veramente male.
Grazie a questa meraviglia che è Wikipedia
io vado a cercare,
perché mi ricordavo che era successo
qualcosa in Africa.
In effetti, è successa
una cosa in Africa, meravigliosa:
che nel 2003, in Liberia,
un gruppo di donne
guidate da Leymah Gbowee,
una donna che aveva una radio,
attraverso questa radio
mobilita delle donne, e dice:
basta con questa guerra civile,
durata cinque anni, coi bambini soldati,
e altre cose terrificanti.
E propone lo sciopero del sesso:
non va tanto bene, non funziona tanto;
però, la mobilitazione delle donne
era talmente forte
che quando iniziano i colloqui di pace
tra i guerriglieri e i governativi,
che si sono svolti in Ghana,
nel Paese vicino,
le donne partono dalla Liberia,
circondano il palazzo dove si fanno
queste trattative di pace -
sarebbe interessante farlo anche adesso -
lo circondano, e dicono:
voi non uscite più di qui.
Finché non fate la pace, non uscite.
Nel testo fatto per i bambini, era:
"Nemmeno per fare pipì?".
Nemmeno per fare pipì. Non uscite di qui.
No, non si può uscire.
E ci riescono, ci riescono!
Ed è stata fatta la pace.
Le donne che hanno accerchiato il palazzo,
hanno imposto la pace.
Non solo: l'amica di Leymah Gbowee,
un'altra donna, è stata eletta.
È stata la prima presidente donna
eletta in Africa.
Non solo, ma è stata anche quella
che ha fatto le scuole
elementari gratuite.
A casa erano felicissimi.
La cosa interessante -
capite che noi abbiamo ragionato tanto
su un'idea di 2400 anni fa,
che arriva in Africa
ed è presa da un gruppo di donne
che la fanno diventare una lotta politica.
Questa è la cultura!
Ecco, con i bambini
abbiamo ragionato su questo:
questa è la cultura.
La cultura è vedere Giotto
che ci racconta come è il Mediterraneo;
la cultura è andare
fin nella Grecia di 2600 anni fa,
per capire una cosa
che successe in Africa 20 anni fa.
È questo spostamento continuo.
E questo spostamento continuo
c'è, ed è possibile,
solo se tutti sono chiamati
a ragionare sempre su tutto.
Che vuol dire questo?
Che dobbiamo fare molte meno cose,
darci molto tempo,
non fare cose urgenti
e fare cose importanti -
va bene anche per la didattica.
Perfetto.
E le cose importanti
sono trovare alcuni elementi
attorno a cui discutere,
e ascoltarsi, e ragionare.
Perché giustamente Maia,
che era la nostra
grande guida della classe,
ha detto:
"Che bel regalo che ci ha fatto
Erodoto, con la storia".
Perché senza la storia,
come avrebbe fatto Martin Luther King
a sapere di Gandhi,
e a fare la nonviolenza?
Era entrata nel loro modo di pensare.
Questo imparare gli uni dagli altri,
continuamente sfruculiare.
E l'ultima frase,
che per me è la più bella definizione
della nonviolenza che abbia mai sentito,
data da Emilia.
Ah, aspettate: una piccola
parentesi, prima.
Abbiamo scoperto che Erodoto -
non so se lo sapete,
forse lo sapete tutti -
Erodoto era figlio
di una greca e di un persiano:
era un sangue misto, un bastardo;
e a me appassionò tantissimo l'idea
che la storia è stata inventata
da uno che aveva nel sangue
due che si combattevano tra loro,
come un palestinese
e un israeliano di oggi.
Ed è lui che ha inventato la storia -
anzi, infatti le chiamava
"le storie", giustamente.
Questa bambina, Emilia,
che era anche lei la figlia
di uruguaiano e di una belga -
quindi aveva capito la storia -
ha detto:
"Gandhi non dava ragione a uno, ma a due".
Mi sembra una frase meravigliosa.
Che vuol dire "dar ragione a due"?
Non lo so, questo è il mio compito a casa.
(Risate)
Grazie.
(Applausi)